One of the things you pointed out too
was that what you most need to know will
be found where you least want to look
and that's because you haven't already
looked there and so it's a little
different for everyone,
right?
Because your particular place you'd want
to look isn't going to be the same as
your place,
but you're going to have a place you
don't want to look and what you haven't
discovered.
That's where it is and so that's all
partly going to be discovered by you
looking at what you're capable of,
what you're truly capable of,
and you know people especially on the
compassionate and saying,
well,
no,
I could never be like brutal like that
and that could be true,
but you can kill people with compassion
and no problem.
It happens.
That's the Freudian eatable situation.
So think about working in a nursing
home.
So there's actually a rule of thumb,
which I also use to guide my
interactions with children and also with
my clients.
And I would say with people in general
do not do anything for anyone that they
can do themselves.
All you do is steal you.
Just steal it from them.
So imagine you're working with really
elderly people,
you know they have Alzheimer's.
It's like really easy to do things for
them because while it isn't,
because it's really a hard job,
but it might be easier to do something
for them then to let them struggle
through it,
but you just speed their device.
Right.
By taking away the last vestiges of
their independence and you do the same
thing with kids.
It's like struggle through it.
Man.
Did you ever see my left foot?
That's a great movie.
It's about this author whose name
escapes me at the moment.
Brilliant.
It's brilliant movie and the person who
who played the part is Daniel Day Lewis.
I think he went to academy award for it,
but it's about this author in Ireland
who was.
I think he had cerebral palsy and all he
could really do was use his left foot.
That was it.
The rest of him was pretty spastic and
not in,
not controllable,
but he was there.
He was very intelligent.
He was with it and his dad would not
help him.
He had to drag himself up the damn
stairs with his left foot.
He just would not help him.
And what happened was he learned how to
live,
you know,
he actually,
he couldn't function and the movie does
the book which is called my left foot
and the movie does a lovely job of
laying that out,
but you have to be one hard hearted son
of a bitch to let your sudden crawl up
the stairs with his left foot over and
over.
You think about that,
but what's the alternative?
You know,
if he would have been,
and of course he lays this out in the
book,
if he would have been catered to,
he would have ended up just like you'd
expect someone who is always catered to.
So it's a very nice lesson in the
triumph of fostering independence over
the,
over to casual compassion.
That's what I would say.